digamos que tenemos dos bancos el banco
y el banco ve y quizás ustedes sepan que
los bancos todos los bancos pero están
la gran mayoría del dinero que tienen
que han obtenido como depósitos de sus
clientes pero mantienen algo de ese
dinero como reserva unas razones en caso
de que algunos de sus clientes llegue y
les diga oye quiero mi dinero en
efectivo y la segunda razón es porque la
reserva federal del banco central les
ordena que mantengan una reserva les
ordena conservar cierta porción de su
efectivo pero podrían imaginarse que
durante el curso de ciertas
transacciones miles de transacciones o
millones de transacciones
15s el banco ve encuentra que la mayoría
de sus clientes llegan y le dice oye
queremos que nos des nuestro dinero en
efectivo y este banco ha dado empresa no
la mayoría de su efectivo por lo que
empieza a quedarse muy bajo en reservas
por otro lado quizás el banco a sus
clientes no le han pedido efectivo o por
cualquier otra razón este banco a tiene
bastantes reservas en efectivo lo que va
a suceder en esa situación es que el
banco a leva aprestar al banco ve algo
de sus reservas
el banco le va a prestar algo de su
efectivo al banco e iba a cobrar cierta
tasa de interés por este préstamo quizás
será una tasa de interés del 5% ese es
un préstamo a corto plazo de un día para
otro por lo que será un 5% diario
normalmente estos préstamos tienen
intereses diarios por lo que el
siguiente día esa deuda va a ser
renegociada para que sea un 5% anual que
sea un interés un poco más pequeño pero
normalmente como les mencioné antes este
tipo de deuda se maneja con una tasa de
interés diaria el banco puede decir esta
es la cantidad de efectivo que te presto
por hoy si lo necesitas de nuevo para
mañana vamos a hablar de nuevo quizás el
interés sea diferente ahora digamos que
la reserva federal que voy a dibujarla
por acá por cualquier razón quiere
estimular la economía es la reserva
federal quieren estimular la economía y
para ello lo que van a hacer es imprimir
dinero vamos a dibujar el dinero en
verde por lo que la reserva federal
comienza a imprimir dinero y quieren
hacer dos cosas quieren inyectar este
dinero en el sistema bancario lo que en
esencia encuentra su camino hacia la
economía y también quieren bajar la tasa
de interés
especialmente las de corto plazo esto
expresamos con tasa de interés diaria
recuerden que esta es una tasa de
interés anual pero es un préstamo de un
día para otro a corto plazo está
recuerden la tasa de interés que se da
con préstamos en un plazo muy corto de
tiempo lo que hará la reserva federal es
lo que se llaman operaciones de mercado
abierto irán al mercado quizás
directamente a estos bancos oa otros
bancos y van a comprar bonos del tesoro
pondrán este dinero en el mercado y a
cambio van a recibir bonos del tesoro o
quizás algo un poco diferente pero por
lo general son bonos del tesoro y quizá
incluso sean compras temporales un
acuerdo de recompra en el futuro y lo
que sucede es que este efectivo llega a
las manos de las personas que vendieron
estos bonos y normalmente lo van a
depositar en bancos lo pueden depositar
en este banco o en este otro pero el
efecto neto es que en general habrá más
efectivo tanto en los bancos como con
las personas si es más efectivo en el
sistema bancario este banco de acá va a
necesitar menos efectivo porque ya tiene
un poco más necesita menos efectivo por
lo que disminuye la demanda y este banco
de acá va a tener más efectivo por lo
que va a aumentar la oferta este banco
tiene más efectivo que puede prestar
porque a lo mejor algunas personas
tomaron su efectivo y lo depositaron acá
si éste tiene más oferta y este necesita
menos demanda el rango de interés de
préstamo de efectivo va a disminuir por
lo que a lo mejor al lugar de estar en
un 5 por ciento va a bajar a un 4 por
ciento por lo que esto va a disminuir la
curva de rendimiento a corto plazo o el
extremo a corto plazo de la curva de
rendimiento vamos a dibujar una curva de
rendimiento aquí esta es la madurez de
este eje madurez y ese es el rendimiento
digamos que la curva de rendimiento
antes de esto se veía así donde esta
parte de ese 5% aquí es
un día para otro de un día este podría
ser el rendimiento de un año este podría
ser el rendimiento de una deuda a cinco
años
pero al hacer estas operaciones de
mercado abierto la reserva federal logra
ambas metas puede inyectar efectivo en
el sistema bancario y por lo tanto en la
economía y logra que baje la tasa de
interés de préstamos a corto plazo en
este caso la baja un 4% por lo que ahora
debido debido a estas operaciones de
mercado abierto la curva de rendimiento
puede verse ahora así